[Música]
el presidente de Manuel macrón se
dirigió a Francia este lunes el 17 de
abril por primera vez desde la
promulgación de su polémica reforma de
las pensiones en un su mensaje dio un
plazo de cien días en los que prometió
poner al gobierno a actuar al servicio
de Francia proponiendo un diálogo y
también una solución de la situación el
mandatario está buscando relanzar su
mandato al que todavía le quedan cuatro
años en nuestro programa matinales de
ayer lunes Contamos con la visión de los
sindicatos y hoy continuamos el
ejercicio pero haciendo el análisis con
La otra cara de la moneda por eso el
saludo a esta hora es para Philip
volante quien es analista político
internacional y representante del
partido de la República en marcha en
Bogotá philippe Buen día Gracias por
estar en el estudio de directo América
muy buenos días
pero bueno no es interesante porque
Renacimiento entonces lo que espero
justamente macón con su discurso es un
Renacimiento es decir relanzarse
si fuese una nueva campaña es decir que
es preguntó a los franceses de cada 100
días simbólicamente va a caer justamente
para el día de la fiesta nacional o sea
que está esperando que las cosas se
calma vimos con la portada que mostró
Rosa sumergido creo que está muy
sumergido justamente en este momento no
y además es que Renacimiento viene desde
incluso la campaña para este segundo
mandato que no va por buen camino hasta
el momento al menos con las protestas Y
es que precisamente se ha Comparado
mucho la crisis actual con la crisis de
los chalecos amarillos en el primer
mandato ahora macron dice que escuchó la
rabia de los franceses pero se mantiene
firme en que la reforma era necesaria
eso qué espacio deja para el diálogo
complicado porque según los análisis de
la ocd de la ocde demuestra que
justamente la edad de la jubilación eso
tiene que extenderse en varios países
europeos no solamente en Francia de dos
años o sea que en este momento lo que se
está buscando justamente es hacer un
anticipo a lo que puede pasar años o sea
que él está trabajando a largo plazo y
en este momento los franceses piensan
que hay reformas que serían más
inmediatas y ese es el problema de la no
comprensión de justamente este trabajo a
largo plazo que quiere retomar Francia
porque sabemos que en este momento hay
un envejecimiento de la población
europea bastante importante como dijo
con esta imagen que es muy
fuerte mostrando que cuando él entró a
trabajar justamente había diez millones
de gente que reciben pensiones hoy en
día son 17 millones O sea que los
cálculos son simples es decir que la
reforma era necesaria saber si la
reforma era necesaria iniciando su
segundo mandato ese es el problema que
le está reprochando muchos sindicatos
dado la situación de inflación la
situación de crisis que en este momento
el descontento que vimos desde los
chalecos amarillos es decir que Francia
es un país usted Mostrar al periódico
Liberación pero yo voy a hablar para el
periódico del país ya donde todos los
días muestras manifestación que en París
todos los días manifestaciones es un
pueblo que está acostumbrado justamente
a criticar Esta vez si es complicado es
decir que hay un Gap hay un no
entendimiento del gobierno eso es grave
hay un rechazo de las instituciones lo
vimos cuando países
de fronterizos gente que está diciendo
que hay una dictadura en Francia y el
consejo constitucional demostró que
justamente era totalmente legal Bueno
pero Felipe las negociaciones dijo
macron se van a centrar en la necesidad
de mejorar los ingresos de los empleados
de avanzar en las carreras de repartir
mejor la riqueza de mejorar las
condiciones laborales y hablar sobre el
desgaste profesional no sobre esto
llamaron Tuvo una reunión el día de hoy
con líderes empresariales pero los
sindicatos definitivamente se niegan a
sentarse en la mesa con el gobierno
ahora le quiero preguntar está en la
economía francesa en capacidad por
ejemplo de inyectar mejores salarios que
es una de las promesas que que hace
Manuel macron en su discurso Bueno hay
dos cosas es decir que los sindicatos
Primero era una necesidad para ellos
manifestar recordamos que los sindicatos
esos ocho últimos años han perdido un
montón de cotizantes Y eso vive de
cotizaciones es decir que los sindicatos
en Francia están desapareciendo Gracias
justamente eso les permitió revivir es
decir que la gente le está retomando el
hacer de té el aceite que vimos que por
primera vez eso es tremendo y
interesante es una mujer que está
justamente al frente de act la estamos
hablando de eso que había casi
totalmente desaparecido Entonces es una
resurgencia justamente de los sindicatos
que no habíamos en los tacos amarillos
charicos amarillos no había
intermediarios no sabíamos no se sabía
con quién negociar obviamente las
prioridades de Francia es decir que
Joaquín
lo que consta yo voy a asumir que tenía
más joven es decir que lo vemos en este
momento usted habló de Los gremios vemos
que las pymes en Francia no entienden es
decir que ellos habían recibido muchos
subsidios justamente con el tema de la
pandemia Y ahorita que les está tocando
bastante en el bolsillo no entiende
justamente está lo que está pasando al
nivel mundial que estamos en un periodo
de casi recesión de inflación Entonces
es complicado justamente decir que lo
que falta es pedagogía Yo creo que es la
pedagogía de no entender lo que está
pasando Es decir que y creo que esta
reforma Esto va como ya la justificó y
realmente la justificación está
matemáticamente lo que está pasando
recordamos que en Francia la edad de la
jubilación no con esto no va a ser mucho
mayor que otros países hay otros países
que está 67 años y la repartición
todavía es fuerte se cuenta 7% de los
bancos se regresan justamente a la gente
Claro pero claro uno entiende de todas
maneras que es difícil para el ciudadano
de a pie aceptar que aumente su edad de
jubilación después de que hay unas
victorias ganadas en ese sentido
Emmanuel macron establece un plazo de
100 días Usted cree que esto es poco
menos de cuatro meses serán suficientes
para calmar por fin los ánimos después
de cuatro más meses de protestas el
énfasis que hice sobre los sindicatos en
los sindicatos no quiere calmar el juego
recordamos que estar en forma va a
entrar en vigor en septiembre de este
año o sea que yo creo que hasta
septiembre justamente ellos van a tratar
todo lo que puede justamente para tratar
de parar esto y darse a mostrar que
justamente es un movimiento para tener
más el problema es que los desmanes que
hay unos grupos que están justamente
haciendo reivindicación que no tiene
nada que ver con el tema este se está
mezclando todo en este momento y ese es
el problema de de Francia usted habló de
desinformación justamente y vemos que
hay una parte desinformación ahí están
poniendo aceite sobre el fuego muchos
como hacía partidos y se nota porque en
este momento vemos que el partido que
más está creciendo es como se llama
gasolina nacional y eso preocupa ahora
ya nos quedamos sin tiempo Yo le
agradezco se nos pasó muy rápido esto
rápidamente en pocas palabras qué cree
usted que sigue en la agenda
gubernamental Bueno lo que sigue la
frase me gustó justamente mostrando que
en cinco años se podía reconstruir la
catedral nodal entonces todo se puede en
Francia Entonces yo creemos que hay una
posibilidad es decir que el pueblo
francés Es capaz justamente de superar
esta crisis y en los ánimos pueden
cambiar entonces podemos ver un cambio
de ánimos justamente la población en
este momento lo que le falta chispa al
gobierno y chispa los franceses pues
vamos a ver Muchísimas gracias Felipe ya
ha estado usted por aquí conversando con
nosotros sobre este tema de la reforma
pensional y no me sorprende verlo
Próximamente otra vez en directo Muchas
gracias y quería agradecer a los
franceses que votaron a las últimas
elecciones justamente para diputación de
los franceses de América Latina y Caribe
Bueno aquí hay espacio para todas las
voces gracias a usted y a nuestros
televidentes sigan con nosotros ya
volvemos con más de directo América
[Música]